now it's time for tonight's hashtagwars
so this is a very cool thing that I'm
excited to report to you the new movie
office Christmas party's in theaters
right now in the cast features some
@midnight favorites take a look noe just
under so front we got Carroll you know
any blue yeah our family you gotta check
out all right this is what's fun about
this we're teaming up with this movie
for some very very awesome things for
every tweet tagged in tonight's hashtag
war at midnight and office Christmas
party will donate $1 up to $30,000 to
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
[Applause]
born Louisville raised in Memphis st.
Jude was our local charity a my dad's
favorite charity and one of my favorite
charities and they do amazing work to
understand treat and defeat childhood
cancer plus they freely share every
discovery they make so that doctors and
scientists worldwide can save thousands
more children and all of you playing
along tonight we'll send them real money
that can be put to good use so pull out
your phones make the world a better
place with tonight's hashtag Christmas
in three words
examples might be presents presents
presents and creepy co-worker mistletoe
I'm gonna put 60 seconds on the clock
and begin
Erica Rhodes eggnog flavored everything
yes points
Holly Secret Santa sucks all right
points Nate no present you all right
boys
thank you for helping out st. Jude
research all right boys meet Chinese
food you boys underwear again boys hate
mistletoe above crash points Erica
please be over
Boyd's thanks mistletoe above butthole
oh boy
who bout this